rachel is with us rachel is in Michigan
hi Rachel how are you hi thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up I was calling because we
are struggling to even get that $1,000
in to start our emergency fund we are
struggling to even stay current on a lot
of our bills so we're just kind of
wondering we focus on $1,000 emergency
fund should we do we get current first
we're just kind of so far behind are you
um we're not right now we're not behind
on anything because books to reading the
Total Money Makeover I realized my pain
for two auto policies one in the state
we previously lived in and then the one
we live in right now and so we are not
usually current today it's just very
tight well it's a whirl in the current
because we got a refund next month or I
don't think we'll be able to pay all of
our bills then something's got to go
doesn't it but we don't know what to go
because we get off our cars
you have zero opponent so what is your
household income we bring in 70,000 okay
so we're $70,000 going to where you're
completely broken in the hole so we have
one hundred and eighty two thousand
dollars in debt
we have one hundred and fifty thousand
and student loans both undergrad and
graduate school we have a little bit of
credit card and a lot of medical we have
two daughters with serious medical needs
that you need to pay weekly and so we
have a copay weekly and we're just and
we're still pains or other hospitals
what is the nature of their medical
condition so one of them has a heart and
kidney issue and so she has to have
blood pressure checks or any regular
appointments there our other daughter
has a stroke and she has a
or disorder and so because of her stroke
we do weekly physical therapy and then
because of the tumor disorder and the
stroke she has seven different
specialists that we see on the regular
goodness so we have a lot of medically
to children yeah we have one more child
um but she is healthy you guys have had
your plate full I'm so sorry
Wow how much is your house payment are
your rent
um no our house payment is thirteen
hundred a month
1513 Oh thirteen okay yes and what does
your husband do what's this master soon
so he works in finance but his master's
in human resources he is um yeah when we
moved he was able to find this job in
finance and so he's been working in that
and I'm guessing on occasional trips
that you're taking care of the kids
right no I'm actually a full-time
teacher oh wow yeah and so I use my sick
things and so does he to do all of the
medical trips and then we do a lot of
them after work so I as soon as I get
out of work I rush pick up our kids and
then run to the hospital alright let's
um prioritize if nothing else number one
you've got to be on a written budget
planning each month before the month
begins and in a coming in a coming
thirty days you do know what your
medical is going to look like in the
coming thirty days okay and so your
detailed written budget that the two of
you are on is absolutely vital the
second thing is once you do that we
prioritize food is first not eating out
not a bunch of fatigued food but food is
first this family eats mm-hmm second
thing is lights and water you should
never be behind on those two you have
plenty of money
yeah you should never be behind on those
two the third thing is shelter you
should never be behind on your house
right your house payments not out of
line the no so food shelter clothing
transportation utilities keeping the
cars running and they're paid for you
told me right yes they're paid for and
we were clean we heard about you last
spring and so as soon as we heard about
you we got rid of our expensive car and
we went and got a $7,000 car and now we
have zero car payment
yeah he's sunk if hadn't done it he'd
been a mess so once you've done those
things then the next priority is the
medical because you have to keep these
providers paid to be able to keep the
proof to be able to keep the help coming
for your babies and we have to make that
a food shelter clothing transportation
utilities and basic medical is
absolutely vital okay then then from
there the credit cards and the student
loans if something has to get behind it
needs to be the student loans okay and
call them call some of them and put them
on hardship deferral that's your
short-term plan and my guess is the more
you live to tighten the budget and you
tighten the budget in order to make it
for a while in order to maintain for a
while then you start to see his income
come up because my guess is he's not
making any money if you're a teacher in
the household income 70 he's like yeah
he's not making very much no and he did
give a second job because we read the
Total Money Makeover in December and so
he went got a second job and as soon as
the summer comes up I was going to get a
second job as well I think you could use
some tutoring you could do some tutoring
and make more than anything else you
could possibly do but the answer to your
equation is for him to get a career
because he's made he's making 1520
thousand dollars a year right
well he's bringing in that much yeah the
gross is a little bit higher but yeah
yeah but he's not making any money he's
got a master's degree in HR
I mean he should be making more than
you're making I agree we're hoping he
will soon
that's the you know either there there's
a tremendous upside to what he has now
and he gets that moving or he changes
and you know develops his career so
that's your long-term answer and you
tread water taking care of necessities
and babies first until then okay and so
I know there's a lot of stress with what
you're facing but you've made the right
choices you take care of those and you
take care of your babies little girls
just they need you to be able to do all
this stuff and you've been a great mom
and a great dad so but the mathematical
answer is more income in your equation
and that's from his career expanding to
what it should have been all along and
you already knew that but that's what
I'm here for I state the obvious but I
understand what you're facing